[Music]
on this Sunday night the major meeting
to mend our Public Health Care system as
Canada's premiers head to Ottawa to
hammer out a deal if the federal
government wants to join me in Saving
that system they have a willing partner
the recommendations the roadblocks and
the non-negotiables
ballooning tensions beijing's strong
reaction on how it's further puncturing
china-u.s relations
Canada's cooling car market how a
stabilizing supply chain is changing the
price of used vehicles and from the
strange but true file a yacht a dead
fish and the house from The Goonies we
put together two and two that it was the
same guy how they're linked to the
arrest if a BC fishing Fugitive
global national with Farah Nasser
thank you for joining us in less than 48
there's a critical meeting will take
place in Ottawa it could determine the
future of Canada's Health Care system
at the table Canada's 13 premiers and
the Prime Minister who are meeting for
the first time face to face since before
the pandemic now each province has its
own story about why the system isn't
working but they all want the same thing
more money from Ottawa billions of tax
dollars are on the line as is a system
in crisis mode Megan King reports on the
expectations and the hard lines ahead of
the first ministers meeting on Tuesday
this pop-up Primary Care Clinic is one
of the many ways Innovation comes into
play when Healthcare is in crisis I have
about 2 000 patients in my practice and
I can't take on new patients and we
field calls every day from people
looking for a family doctor they feel
really terrible about it so this is kind
of my way of contributing we need to
think about the system where we are
today but we also need to think of where
we will be tomorrow because part of it
is you know our needs are different from
what we may have designed a few years
ago so we need to continue to
re-evaluate even as we plan for the
future that point reiterated by Nova
scotia's Premiere as he readies for a
trip to Ottawa with Canada's 12 other
premiers to hammer out a health care
funding deal with prime minister Trudeau
the first ministers have been calling
for the meeting for over two years
demanding the federal share of health
care costs jump from 22 to 35 percent
that's an increase that would amount to
about 28 billion dollars the changes
that are really required are not limited
to things that a single Province can
just chip away at their National issues
I believe in our our public system if
the federal government wants to join me
in Saving that system they have a
willing partner Nova Scotia is all in on
that a different tone than that of
premiers in Ontario Saskatchewan and
Alberta who have opened the door to
Health Care privatization through
expanding Partnerships our priorities
may be slightly different in
Saskatchewan than they might be in let's
say Newfoundland or Nova Scotia and
again possibly even different in British
Columbia BC's Premier says he's
optimistic ready to discuss funding
retention of staff and improved care
we're very much looking forward to hear
the proposal from the Prime Minister
about how we're going to address this
issue of the federal government being a
strong partner in ensuring that Health
Care is there for British Columbians
Trudeau says he won't be signing any
deals with the premiers at Tuesday's
meeting instead focusing on improving
patient outcome and the federal Finance
Minister Christian Freeland has made it
known that the government is in a tight
fiscal environment heading into these
discussions Megan King Global News
to the U.S now a day after a suspected
Chinese surveillance balloon was shot
down by a military jet the job has now
begun of examining debris from the
device to figure out what intelligence
it gathered and beamed back to China
while it flew over some top secret
military sites and as Jennifer Johnson
reports Beijing is already firing back
threatening repercussions
they just shot it some debris from the
down Chinese spy balloon is now being
examined by U.S military forensics teams
see the smoke coming from it as China
threatens to retaliate in a statement
China's Ministry of Foreign Affairs
criticized the U.S for an obvious
overreaction and Syria's violation of
international practice further
escalating an already tense situation
clearly this was an attempt by China to
gather information to defeat our Command
and control of our sensitive missile
defense and nuclear weapon sites
questions remain as to why the balloon
wasn't brought down within minutes of
entering U.S airspace last week it was
first detected north of the Aleutian
Islands on January 28th Republicans are
pointing the finger directly at U.S
President Joe Biden who was advised
civilians could be hurt if the balloon
was shot down over populated areas he
allowed a full week for the Chinese to
conduct spying operations over the
United States over sensitive military
installations U.S China relations are
already strained disputes over beijing's
support of Russia and its war against
Ukraine and Military threats against
Taiwan and Japan analysts say this now
proves to Americans that China is a real
threat it showed the extent of China's
spying program and what they're willing
to do to gather intelligence from the
United States the Pentagon says U.S
defense took steps to block the balloon
spying capabilities military jets shot
down the surveillance balloon off the
coast of South Carolina Saturday
afternoon after it traveled across at
least 11 states suddenly we saw
something take off from the jet knew it
was a missile and you could see the
explosion debris from the balloons
spread across 11 kilometers local
residents are being warned some of it
may flow to shore this is obviously a
federal investigation we don't want to
tamper with any evidence the evidence
may be critical although the U.S
military has already concluded the
balloons technology didn't give the
Chinese significant intelligence beyond
what it can already obtain from
satellites but the Fallout for U.S
Chinese relations will be much more
damaging
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
Iran's supreme leader Ayatollah Khamenei
has pardoned thousands of prisoners
including some who are arrested in the
country's most recent anti-government
protests
Khamenei agreed to Pardon following a
request by the head of the Judiciary who
said many of the young people swept up
by the protests are remorseful and
they're not against the Islamic Republic
but not all the prisoners met the
conditions of release including any dual
Nationals and those accused of
corruption on Earth some of them still
face execution according to human rights
groups up to 20 000 people were arrested
since the protests began in September
many of them teens and young adults with
no political affiliation
former Pakistani president pervez
Musharraf has died in self-imposed Exile
in Dubai
the 79 year old died in hospital after a
lengthy illness Musharraf ruled Pakistan
for nearly a decade after seizing power
in a coup in 1999. he became a key Ally
of the United States after the 9 11
Terror attacks mashar went into Exile
after stepping down in 2008. he was
arrested and charged with high treason
when he returned in 2013. the ruling was
later overturned he left Pakistan for
Dubai in 2016 to seek medical treatment
protests in Peru are growing Bolder and
more violent the civil and political
crisis there shows no signs of slowing
down nearly two months after it started
but now Peru's embattled president is
offering an olive branch of sorts by
promising elections before the end of
the year but critics wonder if it'll be
enough to end Street battles that have
left dozens dead Mike trolley reports
with every bottle rocket flung at police
in Peru's Capital The Divide within the
Andean country deepens
the Congress doesn't represent us as his
protester we have total inequality the
millionaires have all the power they
have justice but the poor people don't
[Applause]
it's a complicated situation the largely
indigenous protesters are angry former
leftist president Pedro Castillo was
impeached in December they're demanding
his replacement Dina buluarte resigns
along with new elections and
constitutional reform baluarte who
initially refused to Cave to their
demands has now proposed elections for
October
partidarios put aside a party interest
she says it's time to think of Peru we
cannot plunge the country into
uncertainty and anxiety
but Peru it appears is already there for
the last eight weeks protesters have
blocked roads in airports burned at
buildings and impacted the second
largest copper producer in the world
from transporting its goods tourism has
also been affected with Canada calling
the situation volatile and urging
non-essential travel be avoided
Peru's Congress has debated Solutions
but with 13 different parties
represented in Parliament bickering has
overshadowed any hope of consensus and
compromise
we have dysfunction in Parliament it
says this Congressman the population is
punishing us for our inability to agree
an agreed upon election would be a start
but Peru has far deeper issues to
resolve micro Lake Global News
foreign
Pope Francis has completed his trip to
parts of Africa with an open-air mass in
South Sudan's capital Juba in his
message to the thousands who gathered
Francis called for the country to build
relations on peace and steer away from
the country's violent past the visit was
the Pope's first visit to the DRC and
South Sudan but his 10th visit to the
continent and part of this visit's
significance was in its partnership
between faiths with leaders of the
Catholic Anglican and reformed
Traditions all taking part a degree and
a job don't always go hand in hand
coming up why black Canadians are often
forced to work in jobs that they're
highly overqualified for
the 2021 census is revealing a big
divide when it comes to education levels
in the workforce data shows black
Canadians are more likely than any other
group to be overqualified for their jobs
Kyle Benning explains
the Canadian economy has seen labor
force issues as it's re-emerged from the
covid-19 pandemic but for Canada's black
population Workforce problems are seen
as systemic Agape assessor learned it
firsthand as a team having to lean on
community organizations and Social
Services to be able to navigate and
figure my way out in this country
um has been was a challenge black
Canadians are the most overqualified
racialized group when it comes to
employment that according to 2021 Census
Data recently released by statistics
Canada the average overqualification
rate is 11 but for black Canadians it's
16 even when you put in all of the
different controls and factors that tend
to contribute to differences in jobs and
in wages it does not fully explain these
kinds of disparities statistics Canada
considers overqualification as people
who have reached a bachelor's degree or
higher from a post-secondary institution
but are working jobs that require a high
school diploma for other racialized
groups like South Asians and Latin
Americans stats Canada noted they had
higher overqualification rates because
of accreditation issues for degrees from
International universities but for
Canada's black population it didn't
matter whether it was a recent immigrant
or a settled Canadian the rate of
overqualification remained around 16
percent
Carl James is a York University
Professor who has researched education
and Heritage he says the societal shift
is needed so black graduates can reach
their full potential what message are we
given to the student how might young
people read that and and as uh as
possible
to their detriment these barriers are
what convinced cassessa to work at the C
Center for young black Professionals in
Toronto but she says until that shift
happens the cycle will continue there's
also this facade and this carrot dangled
that says like we're inclusive we want
to to do better and we
um you know we everyone is able to kind
of meet their dreams here and that's
just systemically not true Kyle Benning
Global News
in the market for a car ahead we'll tell
you why buying used might be a better
bargain but there's a catch
if you're planning to get a new vehicle
for yourself and maybe save some cash by
buying used you also might want to have
a little more patience after Riding High
and a spike in sales over the last few
years there are signs they used car
market is cooling down and that could
mean relief for Canadians looking for
better Bargains Vanessa Wright explains
if you purchased a car during the
pandemic it might have been a tougher
process than usual the new car market
you can't even get them you got to
pre-order wait three four five six
months to a year to get a car the
problem is twofold new car manufacturers
fell behind on production due to a
shortage of important car parts like
microchips and batteries customers began
experiencing extended wait times on
orders with no breaks in the price so
the new car purchase experience which
should be a very exciting fun experience
became more like ordering a meal and
that really was removing a lot of
the excitement that would go into the
purchase and also removing the control
by the customer and more so placing it
right back on the manufacturers of the
of each brand the lack of Supply drove
up the price of used cars as a result
they were able to offer customers an
older model of a car they wanted that
was gently used but readily available
the big surprise at the beginning was
the fact that the used Market went so
high due to that lack of imagery in that
supply and demand this won't be the case
for long though if projections hold true
electric automakers like Tesla are
quickly solving issues they faced during
the pandemic and thanks to the law of
Economics that means a natural dip in
the prices for used cars we will see the
uh the used vehicle Market uh softened
and and decline in Canada
um but you know what it's more of a
return to normal it's it's not a crash
it's just cooling off past the peak and
frankly it's just a return to more of a
normal business cycle or business
environment the decrease in used car
prices is projected to come in the
middle of the Year experts are saying
the best thing for Canadians to do right
now is just wait that is if you can
afford to Vanessa Wright Global News
Halifax
[Music]
next we've got a fisherman's tale you
have to see to believe
[Music]
an unusual case has left police
scratching their heads on both sides of
the Canada U.S border last week a 36
year old man widered in BC was detained
all the way in Oregon that wasn't before
he drew plenty of questions over how he
got there and a daring rescue that led
to his arrest now this is a bizarre
story straight out of the movies
in fact it even involves one as Jasmine
Bala reports
the mouth of the Columbia River known as
the graveyard of the Pacific it was a
Mayday call over the radio this boat its
next victim at that time various Coast
Guard assets were put into motion
including students from the Coast
Guard's Advanced helicopter rescue
school who were training nearby
conditions on scene were approximately
20 foot seized and extremely heavy winds
at about 10 40 a.m a trainee jumped into
the water swimming to the boat seconds
before it capsized he was brought back
to air station Astoria and uh he was
mildly hypothermic and you know suffered
some minor injuries back on Shore the
man was taken to hospital and the rescue
swimmer no longer just a trainee and
actually within a few hours of coming
back on ashore graduated from the school
so it's a heck of a graduation day and a
heck of a first rescue to kick off his
career and the Mariner was released from
hospital but that's when things took a
turn we put together two and two that it
was the same guy and we have since
learned that he stole a boat from the
port of Astoria but there's more only a
couple days earlier another incident
involving the same man and a local
landmark in town a home that starred in
a popular movie it went up to The
Goonies house covered the cameras with
stickers a bit of fish on the porch and
then was dancing around the property and
it doesn't end there Jericho labont is
wanted on BC wide warrants Victoria
Police putting out this poster only two
weeks ago the charges against him
criminal harassment mischief and three
counts of failure to comply the charges
are adding up the longer he's out and
unfortunately the hospital he was
released from the hospital before we
connected the dots and realized that it
was the same person but the story
finally reached a conclusion late Friday
night labont was arrested ending a
bizarre series of events that even this
veteran police chief no I cannot say
that I has never seen before jasimbala
Global News
what a story and that's global national
for this Sunday night I'm foreign Oster
and on behalf of our whole crew here on
global national I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us tonight's here Canada is Indian
Head Saskatchewan we love senior Canada
so please keep emailing us those photos
to viewers globalnational.com Donna will
be back with you tomorrow until next
time take care of yourselves and take
care of each other good night
[Music]